- Susan G wrote get a
puppy. They said, oh no.
Anyways, so that our
puppy will not do this.
(Intro music) (Dog barks)
All right, everybody. So April 11th is
National Pet Day. So you
know what that means.
Happy Pet Day, all the pets out there.
We love our animals. We
love animals at our house
but there's only one
thing that I love more
than animals, and that's reading stories
about when your animals behave badly
and I feel good about my animals.
I can't wait. So let's see everybody's
naughty pet stories.
(Upbeat music)
Pam wrote Scarlet, trying to act innocent.
Like she's never, ever
seen that garbage can.
Nobody was buying it. I
can't wait to see this.
Oh my God it's on her head.
(Laughs)
She is like, what? Oh
my God. She was trying
to get in there. Now she can't get out.
She's like, she's like,
look, you caught me,
but help me get out. That's amazing.
She was like nothing to see here.
There is nothing around
my neck right here y'all.
(Upbeat music)
So many Michelle sent in this photo.
Let's see, I ate glittery
Christmas ornaments
and now I have fabulous disco poo.
(Laughs)
Oh my gosh. That's
awesome. I hate glitter.
My daughter just got this slime thing
and my son and the glitter's all over our
floor everywhere. It's everywhere.
You can't get it out anywhere.
Anyway. Yay glitter. I hope you're happy.
(Upbeat music)
Okay. So this is our
naughty toucan Kill Bill.
Here we go. Oh, I stole Alex's keys
from her pocket and hid them at the bottom
of my cage. So everyone
had to stay a half hour
after work and sit through bird poo.
That's why. Awesome. Um that's funny.
And I love that you called
your toucan Kill Bill.
That's a beautiful bird. That's what we've
learned here today people.
(Upbeat music)
Okay. So Tammy Colmets
wrote, thank goodness.
I don't have a picture, but we were
at my mother-in-law's house for a party
and had our dog with us and then it
was going great until someone noticed
our dog chewing on something.
My mother-in-law realized it was Fred
from under the bed, a
large, very realistic
adult item. Everyone was laughing
hysterically including my mother-in-law.
You better get it mother-in-law
because everyone was laughing
and giving him attention
he was running around
with it in his mouth.
After three, three of us
wrestled it out of his mouth.
I handed the chewed up
adult item back to my
mother-in-law mortified.
Oh my gosh. That's funny.
And I kind of wish she had a picture.
(Laughs)
That amazingly funny. I love that your
family was like, well.
Three people trying to
get it out of his mouth.
Come on. Oh man.
You should have put in
a drawer or something.
I don't know, like under the bed.
Fred from under the bed.
(Upbeat music)
Okay. So Colleen Franks wrote our
extremely angelic but
sometimes naughty pony
named Story, as usual
taking whatever she wants.
Oh!
- [Girl In Video] Hey! No!
- Just took the sandwich.
- [Girl In Video] You can't eat bacon!
- You can't eat bacon, and the pony's
Like yes I can. Oh my gosh.
Just took it right out of her, her hands.
That's rude.
(Upbeat music)
Okay. Amy wrote, I guess the pandemic
hasn't just been hard for us humans.
- [Girl In Video] What
are you doing Ernie?
What are you doing Ernie?
- Oh my Gosh.
- [Girl In Video] Ernie,
what are you doing buddy?
Ernie! Ernie, you cannot drink that
- Get it. Yes, you can.
- [Girl In Video] No, sir.
What are you doing? Ernie?
- Look at him, he likes it
- [Girl In Video] Stop.
- Oh my gosh. He liked it.
(Upbeat music)
Patty wrote my dog, Logan burnt down my
entire kitchen by trying
to get the pizza box
off the stove and
accidentally turning it on.
Which set the pizza box on fire
and then the rest of the kitchen.
Everyone including Logan was fine.
And when we fixed the kitchen,
we got an electric stove.
Here's the thing too. Or just,
you could just put your
pizza in the refrigerator.
(Upbeat music)
Hope wrote, when it's hot, my naughty dog
would dig up our planter and bury his butt
in there to cool off.
Just put his butt in it.
I mean, that's awesome.
Wait, what? Oh my God.
Look at that face. That face is adorable.
Can't even get mad, cause he is adorable.
(Upbeat music)
Okay. So Sandy wrote my little Ozzie
didn't want to go for walkies outside.
So he's hiding. I wonder where he is?
Oh, he didn't wanna go for what dog
doesn't wanna go outside. Oh my God.
The see through drape. Yeah.
It's sheer Ozzie.
So, oh my gosh. Why?
Wouldn't all dogs wanna go
outside? Maybe it was raining.
My dogs will not go
outside if it's raining.
It's like, it's like it's acid to them.
I don't know what,
every dog I've ever had.
It's weird.
(Upbeat music)
Melissa wrote, we have two parakeets
who are mates who we
let fly around our house
on their own because they always come back
to their cage. When she was about to
lay eggs, they started making a nest.
So we'd leave straw and
small twigs around for
them to make a nest with. One afternoon,
I saw something strange and hairy
in the bottom of their cage.
They had stolen my hair extensions
from my room and used it
as part of their nest.
That's smart. I couldn't
pull apart the nest.
So I let them keep it.
My kids now ask mommy
are you going to put
your nest in your hair
today? Are you?
That's amazing. You know what? It's smart.
Looks like a giant hairball.
(Upbeat music)
Susan G wrote, get a
puppy. They said, oh no.
Cause here's the thing,
we just got a puppy.
And we're about to, I'm about
to go, to go pick her up.
And I'm a little nervous,
anyway so that, oh my God.
Our puppy will not do this.
What? In all truth, if I came home to this
I would probably leave
it and close the door
and cry and pretend it
didn't happen for a minute.
Then I'd get to it later. But like that,
I'm so nervous right now.
I'm really hoping Charlie Brownie,
our new little dog.
- [Voice off screen] What is that?
- My daughter named our, this is funny,
It's not that funny maybe,
but I think it's funny.
My daughter named, named our new
little puppy Charlie,
because I came up with
the cute name Dolly and she was just not
having it, and she was like, no, Charlie.
And I was like, it all ends in lee
I was like, what? What's
the big difference?
And I said, wait, why,
if you name it Charlie
they're gonna think it's a boy maybe.
You know, but Charlie's
a cute name for a girl
but they might think it's a boy.
And she was like, who, who
cares what people think?
And I was like I am raising a
beautiful, bold little girl.
So anyway, so I was proud of that.
And then she said, you know like from
Charlie Brown and I was like, okay
well how about we call
her Charlie Brownie?
Cause brownies are awesome and it sounds
kind of girlish. So anyway, we're calling
her Charlie Brownie,
not as excited for you.
Like what? Hope my dog doesn't do this.
And if so, I'll bring a picture next time.
So I could show you my naughty puppy.
Comment below and tell me your naughty pet
stories and hit subscribe.
You know, you want
to do it. So just lean in. All right.